hi there about to start my day of Korean
studying but I want to talk a little bit
about what i would call language freedom
again with reference to the situation in
Ukraine notice I'm learning now not to
say the Ukraine there was a report in
the paper that the leader of the Swoboda
or freedom party which is in fact quite
a far-right party according to the press
again it's so hard to tell from just
reading the press because different
journalists have different axes to grind
but the leader who has some
unpronounceable Ukrainian named here on
a book or something I'd have to hear it
a few times before I could be able to
pronounce it supposedly said that
Russian should be speaking Russian
should be criminalized in the Ukraine
which I'm sure he can't have said
something so stupid but the issue in the
Ukraine is the official status for
Russian my understanding is that close
to a quarter of the citizens of the
Ukraine speak Russian as a first
language regardless of whether they are
ethnic Ukrainians ethnic Russians or
whatever and that the Yanukovych in 2012
brought in a law which made made it
possible in any region of the Ukraine
where a language had more than ten
percent of the population speaking that
as a first language that it would
achieve official status I have no idea
what official status meant and now the
new group have decided to repeal that
law and that gets the Ukrainians
fighting amongst each other like nothing
else um I mean in Canada we have similar
issues the province of quebec french has
official status in Canada but has
official status and only one only two
provinces Quebec and New Brunswick
English does not have official status in
Quebec although probably three-quarters
of three-quarters of a million people or
more speak English as their first
language in Quebec and I don't think
that's by itself a problem because
if people can go about leading their
lives freely using whatever language
they want I think that's the main thing
official status implies that everything
has to be translated into these
languages all laws all documents
everything and it becomes again sort of
bureaucratic overkill but in Quebec of
course they go beyond just giving French
official status or denying English
official status I should put our point
out by the way as a result of the
measures taken to protect the French
language in Quebec primarily as a result
of that probably I don't know half the
english-speaking population over the
last 20 30 years has left the problems
problem Quebec is that in the in
addition to this official status issue
they seem to bound and determined to to
discourage bilinguals and to deny the
fact that city of Montreal is in fact
very bilingual fear in the center of
Montreal you can speak English or French
and you meet people who are quite fluent
in both and now the government recently
came out said you know this is bad we
have creeping creeping bilingualism as
if it's something evil they even had a
minister you know because in Quebec this
you have alternate between the
separatists and Federalists who run the
province and there is a ministerial said
Montreal is no more bilingual to enroll
this was the minister of government said
that which is I mean complete nonsense
Michelle is one of the most bilingual
places in the world Rome is not
particularly bilingual at all and now we
have this lady saying you know we have
creeping bilingualism it's okay people
learn languages on their own like
English Spanish matter but now the issue
is English because that's the biggest
language group is like close to ten
percent of the population speaks English
as their first language and if you
include people who might have been born
speaking Italian but now speak English
is probably a larger number she says
there's a difference with what is
institutional know in other words
anything anything institutional has to
be French and we have to apply that
without mercy
says so company that for example she's
upset that people greet customers by
saying bosu hi that that's not good you
should only greet them saying Bonjour so
and there's all kinds of stories on the
excesses of the sort of language policy
in Quebec where they prosecute italian
restaurants for calling pasta pasta
instead of pat and things of that nature
what's wrong with being bilingual Sweden
is more bilingual in Quebec English is
much more widely spoken in Sweden than
in Quebec it hasn't heard the Swedish
language allowing English to be widely
spoken in Quebec encouraging
bilingualism encouraging the use of
English the most widely used internet
international language is not going to
hurt the French language it's up to the
speaker's of French to you know improve
the quality and the level and and
usefulness of that language so that's
just the Quebec example but then if we
go to the Ukraine I don't know what's it
criminalized Russian I mean whatever the
reasons are that the Russian is spoken
so widely having to do with czar's
russia soviet union I don't know those
people are there and that's the language
they use why would you want to put a
stigma on speaking what is in fact an
international language and a very useful
international language in that part of
the world Ukraine is part of that space
russian-speaking space Russian is a
major international language with you
know internationally recognized works of
literature whatever and so for that I
don't understand why you would want to
stigmatize that language the way by the
way in Quebec the separatists have
essentially tried to stigmatize English
as something bad aunty the national
project and it's interesting on
nationalism which is going to be a big
issue in the Ukraine because because a
large percentage of the people who have
been protesting and who now have power
are nationalists and it's interesting
some of these quotes I found here
nationalism is power hunger tempered by
self-deception George Orwell
ah ah see there were some others i have
found here ah you know nationalism is
like cheap alcohol first it makes you
drunk then it makes you blind and it
kills you so there was one that was
pretty good here the difference mean
patriotism and nationalism is that the
Patriot is proud of his country for what
it does and the nationalist is proud of
his country no matter what it does the
first attitude creates a feeling of
responsibility but the second a feeling
of blind arrogance that leads to war
anyway I think that if the Europeans are
going to help the you help Ukraine they
should make very sure that the minority
language rights are protected and it
hasn't been the case even in places like
like Riga I go to Riga half the city
speaks Russian you don't see a Russian
sign Russian has kind of been cleansed
cultural cleansing has taken place I
don't think that's right even though
most of those Russians move there under
the Soviet Union and yes the Soviet
Union and next latvia and there is great
injustice and ten percent of the latvian
population will ship to the do leg and
all this other stuff but we're at now in
the year 2014 and those people live
there and they speak Russian not by the
same token I can sympathize with the
Latvians or the Ukrainians who want to
make sure that that their language
survives and that they would like to see
Ukrainian be recognized as a language on
the same footing as polish as other
Slavic languages which are similar in
some cases comprehensible to other
Slavic language speakers but which is
different so I mean the thing is not
black and white but given some of the
overheated rhetoric coming out of the
Ukraine I really hope that the European
Union watches carefully to make sure
that any government of the Ukraine that
is not inclusive and that is
deliberately basically stigmatizing
certain languages are certain
language speakers or groups isn't
supported in the way of any kind of
financial assistance because I think
language freedom and I clued in this
Quebec and anywhere else where language
hard heads are denying language rights
to a group based on some great national
principle some nationalist ideology that
we don't accept this people should be
free to speak the language they want use
the language they wanted their place of
work and that should be something that
can be reconciled with constructive
measures to build up the education in
the language of the country or the of
the group like in Quebec it's not a
country but it is a semi-autonomous body
politic and they have every right to
work for the survival of French but it
needn't be at the expense of the rights
of English speakers so pretty muddled
situation and so my rent is pretty metal
now I better get back